et si le plus grand ennemi du climat
n'était pas la voiture ou l'avion mais
l'écran nos écrans bonjour guillaume
bonjour de djoko guillaume pitron
journaliste et auteur de l'enfer
numérique voyage au bout d'un lac aux
éditions les liens qui libèrent alors pc
smartphones tablettes quand on vous lit
on se dit que le numéro numérique c'est
un enfer pour la planète pour
l'environnement est-ce que vous n'y
allez pas un petit peu fort parce que
finalement le numérique c'est 4 % des
émissions globales de gaz à effet de
serre on pourrait se dire ok c'est
beaucoup mais peut-être intéressons nous
aux 96 % générés par les transports par
le bâtiment par l'industrie oui mais si
on fait ça on relativise tout et quand
on relativise on y finalement donc moi
le relativisme est un peu un nihilisme
donc je pense qu'il faut regarder en
face chaque poste de pollution et savoir
comment on peut les améliorer et ce
poste de pollution là qui est celui la
pollution numérique c'est un poste de
pollution qui est non seulement
important 4 % des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est quand même plus que
l'ensemble du secteur civil aérien
mondial et puis surtout c'est le poste
de pollution qui croît le plus vite
puisque l'industrie numérique et celle
qui est également croît le plus vite et
à ce rythme là en 2025 on a doublé cette
pollution là donc je crois que c'est
vraiment un des grands chapitres de la
pollution humaine qui s'ouvre ici avec
cette nouvelle pollution numérique et je
crois que c'est sûr qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps maintenant et quand on
regarde l'empreinte en eau en matériaux
en énergie de l'ensemble de l'industrie
numérique mondiale
tout ça c'est le trip d'un pays comme la
france et là on se dit ok mais en même
temps c'est pas si démesuré puisqu'on a
comme 5 milliards de personnes qui sont
connectés au web dans le monde alors en
un sens effectivement c'est vrai je
dirais prêtons pourrait dire ce n'est
que encore une fois c'est une empreinte
matériel qui est quand même très forte
il suffit de descendre dans une mine
pour se rendre compte qu est ce que
c'est que l'impact écologique du mines
un téléphone portable aujourd'hui c'est
combien de métaux à l'intérieur 50 60 70
78 métaux donc c'est 78 mines
différentes mines pour lesquelles il a
fallu des infrastructures de
l'électricité les métaux il a fallu et
raffiné et des impacts écologiques qui
sont très lourd donc à une empreinte
matériel que vous avez donnée qui réel
et puis après il ya tout ce que ça
génère comme comme revues comme comme
dégâts directs et indirects donc on est
comme dans une technologie qui est dite
immatérielle on parle de cloud en
réalité c'est très ma taille s à 4 507
le virtuel en fait c'est d'abord du
matériel et cette économie
dématérialisée elle est douce sophie
matériel j'espère qu'on nous suit ça que
c'est contre intuitif c'est complètement
contre intuitif parce que qui est déjà
descendu dans la soute du net je dire
quand on envoie un email le mali passe
par où ils passent par des datacenter
les centres de stockage des données il
passe peut-être par des satellites le
plus souvent par des câbles sous-marins
mais qui est descendu dans cette soupe
d'une est composé de tout c'est de tous
et de toutes ces infrastructures là pas
grand monde finalement donc nous avons
une relative méconnaissance voire totale
méconnaissance de ce qu'il ya derrière
nos vies dématérialisée censément
virtuel est en fait tout cela c'est 1 1
une occupation de territoires c'est un
un coût matériel c'est un coût en termes
d'émissions de co2 de consommation
d'électricité et finalement toute cette
idée qu'on va dématérialisée nos
existences des matériels et fiches de
paye mettre nos données dans le nuage
dans un car de tout ça c'est
complètement faux en fait parce que
derrière il ya une infrastructure il ya
tout en quoi datacenter d'ailleurs ces
polluants un datacenter saleh passé
odeurs dans un data center c'est un
hangar qui peut faire la taille de cette
pièce dans laquelle nous trouvons il
peut faire aussi la taille de l'immeuble
et dans cet espace là il y à des
serveurs et les saveurs dans lesquels
sont stockés traiter les données et ses
serveurs qui calcule et ses serveurs
selon qu'ils sont plus petit plus un
petit ou grand il y en a aujourd'hui 3
millions sur terre et nous vous moi
david tous les jours somme permet en
permanence connectés avec son serveur
par jour pour nos actions quotidiennes
et ses serveurs il doit fonctionner en
permanence parce que si jamais il ya une
interruption de service mais en fait il
ya plus internet et ça c'est
insupportable pour le consommateur et
donc ses saveurs tournent en permanence
et en réalité il faut beaucoup
d'électricité pour les faire fonctionner
l'électricité qu'on produit notamment
avec du charbon du gaz naturel du
pétrole les énergies renouvelables et
donc c'est aussi là qu'il ya un impact
écologique si j'ai envie de laïcs et
guillaume pitron parce que j'aime bien
son livre mais sinon c'est une hypothèse
c'est quoi le parcours mondial encore
une fois d'un like alors vous êtes en
face de moi eh bien d'abord le like il
va rejoindre probablement le thème 4g
qui se trouve au dessus de l'immeuble
ensuite le signal va descendre le long
des des fibres delà de la fibre qui en
fait fil par les parties communes
rejoindre le revoir sous les saouler
sous les pas des passants il va ensuite
rejoindre un câble en cuivre pour
quelques temps encore puisque orange va
changer que vous savez ces câbles de
cuivre par des câbles en fibres et puis
il a rejoint d'autres câbles cela il va
ensuite problement traverser l'océan
atlantique par un câble sous marin est
stocké dans plusieurs centres de données
côtes américains parce qu'il a
probablement été émis sur un réseau
social américain il va faire son chemin
inverse dans l'autre sens à 200 mille
kilomètres seconde jusqu'à vous donc en
un rien de temps le lay qui aura
parcouru des milliers de kilomètres donc
guillaume pitron 7 cette pollution
numérique elle et elle est réelle mais
elle est et l'invisible et c'est ça qui
pose problème en fait en fait qu'ils
passent complètement cirque on ne la
voit pas et donc on n'est pas capable de
dire ah bah tiens une action numérique
elle pollue rouler en voiture diesel
c'est très concret en termes de
pollution et on le subit immédiatement
ce qu'on respire ce qu'on produit or là
on ne le voit pas on ne le sent pas ce
sont des infrastructures dont j'ai parlé
qui sont souvent stratégique vital en
cas de guerre qu'est ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui sautent le premier sous
les coups d'une requête en datacenter
qu'est ce qui est le premier coupé par
un acte malveillant c'est un câble donc
en fait on rit on garde ses structures
et ses infrastructures extrêmement
discrète les gars femmes ont pas
forcément tous envie de rappeler qu'ils
évoluent d'abord dans un monde matériel
on les voit partout sur la toile on y
voit nulle part dans le monde physique
parce que rappeler que derrière google
facebook amazon il y à toutes ces
infrastructures polluantes s'est aussi
rappelé
lors leur contribution ou non aux
accords de paris à la transition
écologique est donc aussi une logique
d'un visibilisation tout ça c'est aussi
organisé une certaine manière et donc du
coup on est complètement tenus à l'écart
de cette réalité matérielle là on n'a
pas la perception sensorielle de cette
pollution est le premier des enjeux
c'est de nous éduquer à cela et après le
consommateur ce qui veut l'usagé cia
cette quête de vitesse d'instantanéité
on veut tous avoir en temps réel et la
route effectivement pour la planète
c'est pas top en fait nous voulons tout
tout de suite vous savez le drame il est
là quelque part mais complètement moi
j'en suis persuadé vous savez vous êtes
un rond point et puis vous allez avec
votre le vous laisser guider par votre
google maps et vous allez sortir à la
deuxième sortie par la troisième parce
qu'il ya un décalage entre là où vous
trouver là où google maps vous dit que
vous trouvez vous allez hurler contre la
machine parce qu'elle a une seconde de
retard ce qu'on appelle la latence et la
latence david jacquot cette
insupportable personne ne veut ans tous
veut de l'immédiateté à la micro seconde
près si possible et tout le monde veut
un internet tout le temps disponible 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 et si jamais
il ya un top son service qu'on a vu
récemment avec facebook six heures
d'interruption de service c'est
cataclysmique dans le monde de
l'internet et donc pour éviter cela et
bien aux multiples infrastructures on
les redoute comme on dit volailles sont
pas dans un endroit ils sont donc
peut-être deux trois quatre cinq
peut-être davantage d'endroits sur la
planète de sorte que l'infrastructure
est toujours hyper disponibles et ça ça
a un coût écologique est donc ce qui
coûte écologiquement c'est de vouloir
tout tout le temps tout le temps après
les bienfaits de la tête qu'on va pas
les contester évidemment absolument un
thermostat connectés dans une maison ça
permet d'économiser de l'énergie quand
on voit en somme ça évite pour le boulot
de faire un voyage polluants en avion ça
d'accord là-dessus mais je suis
tellement d'accord l'internet le
numérique en général permet d' immense
gain écologique il faut bien le rappeler
ce qu'il y à ce que l'industrie
numérique souvent insiste sur ses gains
là et on oublie de dire qu'on fasse des
gains il ya aussi des coûts est toute la
question c'est celle du solde finalement
est en vie ce n'est pas parce que quand
on écoute certes le lobby européen du
numérique il affirme que le numérique va
entraîner 10 à 15 fois plus d'effets
bénéfiques que d'effets néfastes sur
l'environnement est ce que bon c'est un
lobby évidemment mais on sait pas au
final vous avez répondu c'est un lobby
comment est-ce qu'on peut être à la fois
juge et partie de ses propres actions ce
qu'il faudrait c'est nous dit une étude
d elle a balancé tu mens et dépendantes
et donc ce qui est affirmé par ces
lobbys là je suis absolument persuadé
après deux ans de requêtes aux quatre
coins du monde sur le voyage d'un like
que c'est faux en réalité personne ne
sait et l'honnêteté me conduit à vous
dire que je ne sais pas quel est le
solde entre ce que ça rapporte est ce
que ça coûte avant l'avènement pour la
planète le numérique et je crois qu'il
faudra voir tous l'honnêteté de dire
qu'aujourd'hui on ne sait pas parce
qu'on n'a pas assez de recul parce que
c'est un sujet tout nouveau nom qu'on
commence à s'emparer pour cela il faut
je pense commencer à réfléchir à l'usagé
du téléphone portable c'est ceux qui
polluent le plus la plus grande
pollution du numérique c'est d'abord les
fabrications abl des interrogations et
l'usagé téléphone portable fallait
conserver plus longtemps il faut les
conserver plus longtemps en fait ils
durent environ deux ans en france à peu
près il faudrait qu'il dure quatre ans
moi j'ai acheté un iphone 7 d'occasions
donc ils avaient déjà été utilisés avant
ensuite il est gelé entre mes mains j'ai
repéré j'ai réparé quatre fois déjà et
il peut encore durer deux ou trois ans
et donc peut-être même davantage donc il
ya vraiment cet enjeu de garder ces
outils le plus longtemps possible c'est
d'abord ça là clés d'un numérique plus
responsable allez merci merci guillaume
pitron donc merci david journaliste et
auteur de l'enfer numérique voyage au
bout d'un lac aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent
[Musique]